doctors are warning against the  tick-tock trend of parents taking their  newborn babies to the chiropractor just  the other day i was talking to our  pediatrician about my two and a half  month old daughter and i mentioned hey  you know what she really loves looking  to the right she doesn't look to the  left as much  the pediatrician said not really a  problem when you feed her put her in a  position where she has to look left hold  stuff stuff up to her left side it'll  resolve on its own and she added now  there are people who ask me about  chiropractors  i don't  necessarily suggest that  and kind of gave me a look and i said to  her oh  i am absolutely not taking this baby to  a chiropractor and she seemed relieved  but probably has to kind of be careful  because a lot of parents think that this  is a good idea  not a good idea and the doctors are very  clear  don't take the baby to the chiropractor